to illustrate the concept of equilibrium
let's say that we have a beaker and we
put some water into our beaker and also
we make sure that our beaker has a lid
on it
some of those water molecules are going
to evaporate and turn into a gas and
eventually once we have enough gaseous
water some of the gaseous water is going
to condense and turn back into liquid
water
to represent these two processes we can
show liquid water on the left and
gaseous water on the right so in the
forward process liquid water turns into
gaseous water and this this forward
arrow here represents the process of
vaporization and when gaseous water
turns back into liquid water that's
represented by this arrow here on the
bottom and so that's the process of
condensation
since we start with liquid water at
first the rate of vaporization is
greater than the rate of condensation
but eventually we reach a point where
the rate of vaporization is equal to the
rate of condensation and when that
happens if you're turning if you're
turning liquid water into gaseous water
at the same rate you're turning gaseous
water back into liquid water the number
of water molecules in a liquid and
gaseous state would remain constant
so when the rate of vaporization is
equal to the rate of condensation we've
reached a state of equilibrium
and this is a dynamic equilibrium
because if we zoom in and we look at
this
uh water molecules are being converted
from the liquid state to the gaseous
state all the time and molecules are
going from the gaseous state back to the
liquid state all the time however since
the rates are equal the number of
molecules in the liquid and gaseous
state remain constant and if we look at
from a macroscopic point of view the
level of water wouldn't change at all
now let's apply this concept of dynamic
equilibrium to a hypothetical chemical
reaction in our hypothetical reaction x2
which is a reddish-brown gas decomposes
into its individual atoms to form 2x and
individual atoms are colorless
so in the forward reaction we're going
from x2 to 2x so x2 is decomposing to 2x
and in the reverse reaction
the two atoms of x are combining
together to form x2
when we have a forward reaction and a
reverse reaction by convention we say
what's on the left side are the
reactants
and what's on the right side are the
products and by using these these terms
we can avoid confusion
let's say that we start our reaction
with only reactants so only x2 is
present in this first container here
and there are five particles of x2
if every particle represents 0.1 moles
since we have five particles of x2 we
have 0.5 moles of x2 and let's say this
is a 1 liter container
0.5 divided by 1 would be 0.5 molar so
the initial concentration of gas x2 is
0.5
molar and since we don't have any of the
x there are no white dots in in this box
right the initial concentration of x
would be zero
molar so let me just write that in here
zero molar
next we wait 10 seconds so we start off
at times equal to zero seconds and now
we're at time is equal to 10 seconds and
now we can see there are three there are
three particles of x2 in our box and so
that would be 0.3 molar so let's go
ahead and write 0.3 molar in for our
concentration
and now we have some particles of x
there are one two three four particles
and once again if each particle
represents 0.1
moles that's 0.4 moles of x divided by 1
or 0.4
molar
we wait another 10 seconds so when time
is equal to 20 seconds now there are two
particles of x2 and 1 2 3 4 5 6
particles of x
so now the concentrations are 0.2 molar
for x 2
and
.6 molar for x
we wait another 10 seconds for a total
of 30 seconds and there are still two
particles of x2 and six particles of x
and so the concentrations after 30
seconds the concentration of x 2
is 0.2 molar and of x is 0.6 molar
notice how the concentration of x2 went
from 0.5 molar 2.3 molar to 0.2 and then
it was also 0.2 after 30 seconds so it
became constant when time is equal to 20
seconds the concentration of x went from
0 to 0.4 to 0.6 and then it was also 0.6
after 30 seconds
so the concentrations became constant
when time is equal to 20 seconds which
means the reaction reached equilibrium
after 20 seconds so at time is equal to
0 was not at equilibrium when time is
equal to 10 seconds it was not at
equilibrium only when time was equal to
20 seconds did it reach equilibrium and
at equilibrium the rate of the forward
reaction is equal to the rate of the
reverse reaction and if that's true then
x2 is being turned into 2x at the same
rate that 2x is being turned back into
x2 and if those rates are equal the
concentrations
of x2 and x at equilibrium would remain
constant
we can see the same concept if we look
at a graph of concentration versus time
the concentration of x2 starts at 0.5
molar when time is equal to 0 seconds
and then drops to 0.3 molar after 10
seconds and after 20 seconds it's at 0.2
molar and then stays constant after that
for for the concentration of x we start
out at 0 molar we increase 2.4 after 10
seconds then we're at 0.6 and then we
are constant
so if we think about a line if we just
draw a dashed line here at 20 seconds
that's the dividing line between on the
left where we're not at equilibrium and
so the concentrations are always
changing and then to the right of that
dotted line we are at equilibrium where
the concentrations remain constant
so the equilibrium concentration of x2
gas
is equal to 0.2 molar and the
equilibrium concentration of x gas is
equal to 0.6 molar
finally let's use these particulate
diagrams to think about what we would
see at a macroscopic level as the
reaction proceeds to equilibrium in the
first particular diagram we see only red
particles so only only our reactants x2
are present in the beginning however as
time goes on the number of red particles
decreases from five in the first
particular diagram to three in the
second
to two and then the number stays at two
because remember we reach equilibrium
after 20 seconds
so what we would see from a macroscopic
point of view is we'd start out with a
reaction vessel
that is a darker brown red and then it
would be a lighter brown red and then
finally when we reach equilibrium an
even lighter brown red and it would stay
that same light brown red
because we've reached equilibrium and
the concentrations of reactants and
products remain constant at equilibrium
even though our reactants are turning
into our products
our products are turning back into our
reactants at the same rate and therefore
the concentrations of both reactants and
products are constant